all right let's answer some questions
first one comes from i don't i'm not
familiar with this twitter handle matt
kc9 i'm not sure who that
is pray for joe burrow with a banged up
offensive line also if you could come up
with a dream fantasy team of halloween
candy what would it be ps mike nobody
cares about your fantasy team thanks
matt casey
joe burrow though no left tackle no
center
no right tackle i mean he'll have one it
just won't be the starter and no joe
mixon
against the titans shireen you know joe
burrow has been great
the only problem is other than mixon no
one around him is
all that good godspeed
joe burrow this does not look like a
good matchup for him you know mixing
will miss his second consecutive game
and all those offensive linemen are out
and
you could be playing an easier opponent
than the titans this week to have to
face
a team without all those guys i mean
this is going to be a tough one for him
and we'll just see what type of
quarterback he is we know he can run
i think he's going to be running a lot
this week
and look this is one of those where i
want to say trevor lawrence are you
paying attention are you watching
closely because joe burrow
and i know this makes people in
cincinnati upset but the truth is he
thought about making a power play
and not playing for the bengals and he's
been spectacular
but look at what's around him and
they're eventually going to get the guy
killed
with even when the starters do play he
gets banged around and uh i i just i do
worry about
joe burrow staying healthy all year long
ham spam thank you man will mike zimmer
get
fired after losing to the packers
this weekend sharing let me just chime
in on this
first and foremost they're not firing
mike zimmer during the season not firing
mike zimmer
after the season but what's setting up
here is next year
he's going to be the guy we put at the
top of the list when it's time to put
the hot seat
coaches together no question he'll be at
the top of the list they absolutely are
keeping my zimmer
after this week they're keeping mike
zimmer after the season
the pressure is going to be on him going
forward frankly and
7-9 in 2014 which was his first year
there was their worst record i think
they're going to have a worse record
than that this year
yeah and i think he's going to have to
string together consecutive playoff
seasons this every other year stuff is
going to have to end
he's going to be hot seat in 2021
and even in 2022 if they if they fall
apart again
he's not going to start hot seat if they
make the playoffs but i think he's going
to be done after 2022 he needs two
straight playoff seasons to save himself
after this year if it continues the way
that it has started so far a red zone
alk is todd bowles proof that some guys
are just better at being an
offensive or defensive coordinator than
a head coach
can we really judge him for what he did
with the jets or judge
anybody for what they did with the jets
i mean really he you know he had the
four years
at the jets and he was 24 and 40. no
playoff appearances
i would love to see him get another
chance i would almost guarantee that it
to comply with the rooney rule that some
guy that some teams give him a chance to
at least
interview but he's been a terrific
defensive coordinator there's no
question about that i do think there are
questions about him as a head coach i'd
like to see him go somewhere else and
see if he can be a head coach
and he's not proof of it wade phillips
and north turner are proof of it it's
already been proven
that they are so good when they become
coordinators again they continue to be
hired as head coaches and it was lather
rinse repeat
multiple times here's what i'll say if
the buccaneers win the super bowl i
think bruce arians walks away
between byron leftwich and todd bowles
one of those guys will be the head coach
the next year it'll be interesting to
see who it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports